I can't believe we're actually gonna do
this
I have never
for one second of my life
ever doubted loving you
the kid will be watching that every day
how is it you can say stuff like that
out of nowhere
you guys keep it down
were we being loud
I'm trying to have a drink
with my friends
oh we were being too loud
is that what it is
get your drunk ass back to your seat
you
you shouldn't provoke them I wasn't
provoking oh my God
what the Andrew are you okay
oh my God what the
somebody call it ambulance Andrew Andrew
look amazing look at me are you okay
open your eyes open your eyes can you
hear me Andrew
foreign
HK P30 German engineered very light very
easy to handle
pretty much good for any scenario it
would carry home protection scrum right
I'll take it